philippe de vol merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors on le
rappelle un ces rassemblements ont été
interdits pour cause d'urgence sanitaire
mais les organisateurs évoquent le droit
inaliénable de manifester quel est votre
regard juridique sur ces deux positions
et bien la manifestation et est
interdite pour des raisons sanitaires ce
qui est peut-être fondé probablement
fondées d'ailleurs je m'aperçois que
dans la foule il ya des gens qui ne
respectent pas les les distances de
sécurité physique et qui ne porte pas de
masque et saas et c'est regrettable et
j'espère que ça ne pourra pas propager
davantage le virus qui est sur la voie
de disparaître alors des rassemblements
contre le racisme et les violences
policières dans le sillage de la mort de
georges floyd aux états unis comment
expliquez vous que ce décès suscite
autant desmoudt d'émotions ici en france
c'est bien sûr que c'est évident
les images que l'on a vues pour lorsque
le ce policier a étouffé avec son genou
aux gens je flotte sont insoutenables
sons sont très difficiles à d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'entre nous aurait voulu
pouvoir porter de l'aide à cet homme qui
était au sol et qui demandait grâce et
d'ailleurs c'est c'est même contraire au
droit de la guerre de la convention de
genève
quand quelqu'un est au sol de noter donc
bah c'est bon on le on le met dans une
dans une position normale qu'ils
puissent être tranquille et qu'on les
écoute au poste et la bombe on assiste
est quand même à quelque chose d'un
soutenable alors l'acte allez je vous en
prie je vous en prie continuez
voilà maintenant on sait que ce policier
et est arrêté et qu'il est inculpé pour
meurtre donc la justice et la justice
doit se faire et moi ce que je crains ce
qui est une manipulation politique pour
eux
heurtée et et mettre à mal la page chez
civile m c'est à dire la paix civile
aussi bien aux états unis qu'en france
et ça c'est un véritable danger parce
que
le droit doit passer et souvent quand je
m'explique sur votre plateau c'est pour
que le droit puisse puisse passer et je
pense qu'il faut éviter de rentrer dans
cet écueil
alors la question des violences
policières a été un vrai sujet de débat
notamment au moment de la crise des
idées gilet jaune c'est aussi un sujet
récurrent outre atlantique la situation
en france et aux états unis est elle
comparable selon vous on a entendu un
des manifestants d'hier il n'y a pas de
frontières sur ces sujets bah oui pour
ceux qui veulent mondialisé le trouble à
la paix civile
c'est quelque chose que l'on peut
exporter en français qui est malheureux
parce qu'on ne peut pas comparer les
actions de la police américaine avec les
actions de la police française ce n'est
pas du tout la même doctrine et ils
n'ont pas les mêmes compétences
donc je pense que ce débat qui est
exporté en france et dangereux je
condamne évidemment tous ces acteurs
assistait aussi bien par des
fonctionnaires des forces de l'ordre qui
doivent être punis par l'oréal et archi
et par la loi parce que le racisme est
condamnée par la loi mais de là à
vouloir troubler l'ordre public
il ya quand même un énorme fossé
on se souvient lors des manifestations
des gilets jaunes notamment lors de
rassemblements interdits de gilets
jaunes que les forces de l'ordre
chargées assez rapidement pour disperser
la foule et faisait usage de gaz
lacrymogène pour le moment même si la
manifestation est interdite
c'est pas le cas depuis près d'une heure
pas de débordement une manifestation
dans le calme
est ce que vous observez finalement un
changement de comportement du côté des
forces de l'ordre où il est encore trop
tôt pour le dire
alors il est peut-être encore trop tôt
puisque la manifestation ne fait que
commencer il faut voir comment vont
évoluer les choses si il ya des
débordements mais il est vrai que lors
des manifestations de gilet jaune
l'action de la police était quasi
immédiate et moi ce que je dénonce
dénonce pas les policiers qui ont faim
de contes sont son milieu de second flea
et qu'on accuse à tort d'être raciste et
et de et d'outragé si vous voulez
beaucoup de personnes en fonction de
leur faciès ou de leur origine raciale
je crois que
un impact contre-productif et sait
mettre notre paix civile qui est bien
fragile en danger mais la répression qui
a été fait sur les gilet jaune a été
particulièrement terrible
est ce que j'accuse c'est
l'instrumentalisation des forces de
l'ordre sur une manifestation à
caractère social et ça c'était injuste
très injuste et d'ailleurs je suis un
peu étonné du silence des gens du show
business sur les violences qui ont été
faites sur les légendes qui ont perdu je
vous rappelle des yeux des mains qui ont
été blessées qui ont été matraquées qui
ont été hospitalisés des blessures de
guerres et jeu j'étais étonné de du
silence du monde des médias et notamment
quand il ya eu la mort de deux célèbres
qui était paisiblement à sa fenêtre et
qui a été qu'est morte suite à des tirs
de gaz lacrymogène et je suis étonné
aussi bien pour cédric un chouïa qui qui
est lui aussi et a été interpellé et est
mort deux sont depuis son interpellation
au mois de janvier et il ya eu un
silence total de la part du show
business alors pour conclure en quelques
mois concernant la question du racisme
dans la police française le ministre de
l'intérieur a décidé de se saisir de la
justice sur deux affaires
comment observer vous cette décision du
premier ministre
c'est normal mais quand il agit contre
des fonctionnaires clic you qui seraient
susceptibles d'être raciste parce qu'il
comme prouvés effet et si les faits sont
établis évidemment que l'action doit
doit agir c'est bien mais je pense aussi
qu'il aurait peut-être dû agir pour
suspendre des fonctionnaires des forces
de l'ordre qui ont été parties
particulièrement plus tôt lors de
manifestations de 2,2 g jaune je pense
aux commentaires
andrieu à toulon qui a été partie de
l'omo lors il n'a jamais inquiété jamais
suspendu donc ces deux poids deux
mesures c'est en fin de compte je pense
que le ministre de l'intérieur et est
pris dans la tourmente médiatique et
veut faire un an d'honorables quelque
part merci beaucoup philippe de veulent
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat au barreau
de paris